after
days of loyalist fury on the streets of
northern ireland
these were used in a nationalist area
confronting police
fireworks were launched at the police
line on springfield road in belfast
youth smashed lumps of concrete to hurl
at officers
for the first time in six years water
cannon was deployed
in northern ireland police water cannon
used against protesters on the streets
of belfast this was a site
many here thought have been consigned to
history
but as we move towards the 23rd
anniversary of the signing
of the good friday agreement this
weekend this goes to show just how far
and how much work has to be done towards
reconciliation here
in northern ireland
last night's trouble came after a week
of protests from loyalists
angry over the northern ireland protocol
which they say brought in an irish sea
border
and the failure to prosecute sinn fein
members for breaching coronavirus
regulations
on wednesday night came clashes between
the two communities
in what police described as the worst
violence in years
the scenes that we saw were absolutely
disgraceful
in terms of the serious criminal acts
that were being carried out
and the violent disorder that was taking
place and it needs to be condemned in
the strongest possible terms
boris johnson has appeal for cam along
with his irish counterpart mijo martin
and now the white house we are concerned
by the violence in northern ireland
and we join the british irish and
northern irish leaders in their calls
for calm
we remain steadfast supporters of a
secure and prosperous northern ireland
in which all communities have a voice
and enjoy the gains of the hard-won
peace
but no one knows for sure who's
orchestrating the ongoing trouble
or if they're listening to the
politicians
there will be more talks today but many
here are apprehensive at what the
weekend will bring
after a week of bitter confrontation
that's injured dozens
but shocked and disillusioned many many
more
stephen murphy sky news in belfast